ثلاثه 83 عاما عمر الفنان عادل امام قضى
منها اكثر من 60 عاما في عالم التمثيل في
جميع مجالاته من الشاشه الكبيره او
الصغيره وحتى على خشبه المسرح ليكون
بالفعل زعيمه المهنه التي احبها ومنحها كل
امكانياته ما يزيد عن 100 فيلم سينمائي
قدمها الزعيم عادل امام ابرزها الارهاب
والكباب بخيط عديله الحريف والواد الواد
محروس بتاع الوزير وايضا السفاره في
العماره كذلك قدم الزعيم نحو احدى عشره
مسرحيه على مدى سنوات ظلت تعالقه في عقول
وقلوب الجماهير منها مدرسه المشاغبين
الواد سيد الشغال ومسرحيه الزعيم وطبعا
شاهد ما شافش حاجه وكانت المسرحيه الاخيره
له بعنوان بودي جارد
وعلى الشاشه الصغيره قدم الزعيم سته عشره
مسلسلا تلفزيونيا تراوحت بين الدراما
والكوميديا اخرها مسلسل فالنتينو عام 2020
كذلك ساهم في مسلسل اذاعي برفقه عبد
الحليم حافظ عام
1973 حمل عنوان ارجوك لا تفهمني بسرعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات